dude
i'm so sorry the trailer came out like a
half hour ago
i know i know you want to have the first
trailer reaction up but if we hurry
right now we won't be that late
greg what are you doing
[Music]
greg are you all right dude you okay
i'm batman
obviously this is our most anticipated
trailer today koi how you feeling i
don't know that i've ever been this
excited for a trailer in my life have
you ever just know a movie's going to
change your life yeah
koi you're going to want to hear
everything he's got to say because he's
an expert guys let's get into it
finally get some edward nick or nash
oh no
oh the seven vibes are immaculate yeah
yes let's go marie still worked hard on
that
fear yeah
[Music]
it's a
warning yes it is yeah
[Music]
oh he wanted to kill him
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
oh this is so beautiful
this continues it won't be long before
yeah
yeah
i don't care what happens to me
it's only gonna get worse for you
oh
[Music]
black and blue and dead all over
this is the greatest trailer ever
oh hell yeah dude look at the stunt work
dude
[Music]
upside down
i love it
i love a good upside down shot boy
i just want to watch that again i don't
give a [ __ ] what anyone says there's
nothing wrong with that they're not a
single thing i won't hear it i wonder if
the movie's perfect i don't give a [ __ ]
glasses i got that is the most perfect
trailer oh yeah oh boy that was like
having a child
i know what it's like to have a baby oh
god yeah that uh that was perfect i am
just loving the way it's shot the way
matt reeves captures this it feels like
perfect blend you know what aussie feels
like is like other matt reeves films
we've seen prior sure but it does have
this flare of christopher nolan but more
comic book panel and that's what i loved
about the way it's been it's looking
like even the the yellow lighting a lot
of the time was making me think of nolan
but more than that there's also like so
much great
reflective lighting happening throughout
this whole trailer from blue to red of a
whole bunch of great color palettes and
that's what i mean just like with the
framing devices right down to the ending
shot with penguin looking at him he's
upside down like a band like man this
feels like a comic book and my main
takeaway that's what we got to focus on
so we're all efficient here my main
takeaway though was i read the comic
batman ego a few weeks ago where he's
basically being confronted with himself
bruce wayne is being confronted with the
identity of batman batman is pretty much
being like you have to cross the line
you have to kill you gotta go to that
that deep dark place let me take over
and that's so much of the impression
that i'm getting in this trailer like
there's this one shot where it's like
yeah they have the romance going on
between him and catwoman when he's like
taking out a guy catwoman's like damn
you're you're freaking psychotic you
know
like i'm loving i got all these
different puzzle pieces here from
penguin to riddler but before koi kicks
so much ass in this talk john get in
there yeah man i agree 100 this looks
like the perfect blend of like a comic
book movie that has the full comic book
range but also the full range of just
cinematic gravitas yeah like this looks
harsh it looks desolate in a lot of ways
and it looks like yeah a more populated
gotham with more up you know like larger
than life characters like the penguin
and catwoman and the riddler and batman
like you know it seems like with the
nolan ones you would have a you know one
kind of focal villain maybe a couple
other people this feels like yeah a more
sort of comic book gotham world where
yeah we can see rise to many other
villainous characters but yeah just the
mood the aura the harshness of
everything music the music yeah for a
year or two to fight for the soul of
batman and to really figure out for
bruce wayne what that soul is
like that's what i got from this and i'm
super excited to see that koi it's okay
i may embarrass
myself you're not embarrassed come on go
for it
this is everything i wanted and more
this feels like a tim sailed wrong this
feels like a david finch drawing this
feels like a clay man painting drawing
this feels like a comic book the frames
the architecture the style the beautiful
cinematography but most of all to me
this feels like a david fincher film
through the lens of matt reeves pacing
matt reeves does an incredible job
letting a frame breathe matt reeves does
an incredible job letting a character be
a character and david fincher does an
incredible job framing so i feel like
david fincher does cinema a service and
matt reeves does actors a great service
now we're putting those together and
we're giving up batman for the ages
through two of the greatest i know
david's not directly involved but the
feeling of this and this to me more than
the other trailer feels like a catwoman
movie this feels like catwoman is as
equally paired as batman and that's the
beautiful duality of batman batman's
duality is he won't kill but he also has
this amazing contrast of emotion towards
catwoman she's a criminal she's the
things he doesn't want to believe in
he's warring on crime but who he loves
is a criminal this whole trailer was
robert pattinson has a clinched fist
his mouth his body language his
architecture as a human being was this
clinch this and everything about it was
him trying not to break yeah and i think
the thing that's gonna break them is
selena kyle we see this beautiful
penguin representation by colin farrell
this mafioso penguin we hear that this
is all a powder keg and riddler's the
match gotham is about to explode and the
entire time batman's trying not to break
his rule while falling madly in love
with the criminal while living in the
most fleshed out gotham i've seen to
date this trailer was cinema and i will
watch it a feature-length amount of time
soon i i could i the expectations were
high it outlived them somehow it's just
so beautiful to behold and colin farrell
looks freaking interesting i cannot wait
to see that to this day
i'm still like oh yeah that's colin
farrell like that's still happening when
i'm watching this like he is
so gleeful and maniacal he just i got
you he really feels like penguin from
the comments and you see why he's got a
show you see why this is an expanded
universe you see why this can go on and
on and on they can make ten of these
they can make a show they can expand
this out and it feels unique to itself
this is like nothing i've seen but the
way they are capturing is ever gnashed
this time around right the way they're
capturing paul dano here feels so much
like yeah that that's the most
seven-esque reminiscent that you get
like that's super fincher just the
framing devices that are used in the
diner and the way the tracking shots
were working but it was gonna get
crazier man there's a one shot where
it's a serial killer live stream yes
like this is year two so i imagine that
with batman here that that traditional
heroic thing is that it brings rise to
right it brings a rise to other villains
in gotham it's like what difference am i
making here in gotham like what how am i
making a difference when these worst
people keep popping up and i'm probably
in some way giving birth to this and i
think am i different from them yeah and
that's what i think catwoman's gonna do
for batman is how he's different from
catwoman and i think we're gonna see her
dealing with the wealth and equality of
gotham he represents this figure that's
partying by being batman he's trying not
to break his rule but that's his outlet
like this guy's a broken billionaire
who's getting out his frustrations
catwoman's getting out of frustrations
from just stealing and being a criminal
doing these things i think we're going
to see a beautiful catwoman origin story
we're going to understand celina kyle
more than we have before and it's going
to be two paths you can take you can
take one path to become a criminal one
path to become a batman and it's going
to be insane yeah give me three hours
give me four yeah i'm i i cannot wait
for this at least three's cut we
even got some alfred penny worth in here
and i gotta say
years ago
when we saw war for the planet of the
apes there's a shot early on when he's
leading up to fighting woody harrelson
in the beginning caesar that is doing
the flash in the cake and when i saw
that i think i said it in the review
that there is a shot early on in the
cave the sequence where you're like that
right there showed me this guy can do
the batman with the muzzle flashes the
muzzle flashes and it's right here in
the shot
like it's yeah i'm like oh my god that's
exactly why i said he could do the
batman is because and that one image i'm
like oh i'm so glad it's here i gotta
pull that clip to find that oh yeah i
called it yeah that i really loved about
about seeing this portrayal of batman is
that as as harsh as he is in that first
teaser we got that scene in the hallway
suggests the two he is deliberate he's
just walking down the hallway letting
them shoot at him and just taking them
down one by one i think robert pattinson
was so cool about what he's doing here a
lot of this is gonna have to be in the
body language with his eyes and such so
you guys know body language he's gonna
do that
but
what's neat is it's more than just
aggressive batman you can feel the
conflict within him this whole trailer
he brings such life in his
eyes where it's like this dude really
wants to kill these guys
he looks like he wanted to push straight
through the glasses
there was ever someone to understand
batman it's a guy that's like i've been
under the lens paparazzi for 10 years
please let me be like robert pattinson
is bruce wayne and i could totally see
him using batman as an outlet and robert
pattinson i think is the most underrated
actor of our generation the man is such
a powerhouse in everything he does let
twilight die this man is batman now i
really hope this answers i'm going to
like you know you're so good
if you've never seen high fidelity zoe
is mind-blowing colin farrell this cast
is impeccable i mean andy circus needs
to not be explained but what they're all
right man they're all embodying
different they're all playing against
type in a way like they all have a
certain archetype they play and they're
doing that through this insane visual
and i don't think we've seen something
look like this much of a comic in a noir
setting today guys what the hell did you
think about
that wow i am sweating and that it's so
crazy when like the first trailer was
such a surprise and then the second
trailer completely delivers that is nuts
uh this is gonna be a massive film and i
can't wait follow koi zhandro clearly
knows what he's talking about check out
john's only fans you could subscribe to
me over on my uh my my napster page
thank you so much for being here oh yeah
and thank you to tony gil for holding
the camera
help us the camera in the sound thank
you and thank you to luis lopez for
doing helping us with the sound design
in our opening sketch